le maître mot c'est sensibiliser les
personnes sur le fait que fort de france
va accueillir un certain nombre de cas
va carnavaliers et qui peuvent toujours
rejoindre l'a6 aussi venise à la boue
sont sécurisées mais tu en as pris les
sans domicile fixe est aujourd'hui la
mission des équipes du samu social
professionnels et bénévoles réalisent au
quotidien des maraudes afin de leur
apporter une aide et leur donner surtout
quelques consignes avant l'accueil est
si populaire des choux gras danger
malgré leurs situations délicates et
leur fragilité psychologique
certains gardent tout de même leur père
au coût élevé des appréhensions
et si sur le boulevard général de gaulle
point central de vider sur deux axes la
présence de cet homme au niveau de la
mutualité n'êtes pas souhaité
physiquement diminué et devra être
évacué c'est un monsieur qui dépend à la
fois de la psychiatrie du somatiques
mais aussi au niveau de la qualité de
l'assistance sociale et nous ferons tout
pour le sortir de là ne serait ce que le
mettre à la rue par une personne pour
qui vont ils mettre les échoppes et qui
trouveront toutes sortes de violence qui
trouveront ce qu'ils feront tout pour le
chasser autre point très sensible le
secteur de la plage de la française très
fréquenté cette femme
affalés sur ce banc nourrissent à peine
quelques mots elle nous déclare qu a dû
se défendre toute la nuit pour éviter
une nouvelle agression le monde de la
nuit est très cruel d'autres habitués à
cette période mouvementée dévider
prendre à leur disposition elle était là
parce que c'est pas pour me voir c'est
pas pour avoir l aval à raul est nu allô
allô
timoko n'a dit mot sur la valeur ajoutée
ainsi que durant le carnaval même si on
va dire tout le monde est dans une
ambiance festive il ya beaucoup
personnes qui consomment de l'alcool
était avec cette consommation d'alcool
les violences sont de plus en plus
grande et le premier a personne qui sont
fragilisés qui sont atteints par ces
violences
violences de groupe sur ces personnes là
il aura donc conseillé de se rapprocher
de tous les dispositifs met à leur
disposition comme ce centre
d'hébergement et de réinsertion sociale
l'assise recommandé par ces courageux
bénévoles et homme de terrain